[Music]
so the money situation itself like women
get paid less to the dollar to the to
the man right but how do you know how do
you know that we're paid less because
we're women i mean you're the stats
ladies because you're going out in the
profession like if you're going to be an
engineer like there's not a lot we're
female in the only but even when it
comes to sports right the only sport
that is paid the exact same money though
no but i'm saying tennis but yeah let's
finish this
that's because respectfully i know i
love you men are better than women at
sports sorry i'm sorry
i'm sorry
i'm sorry you're probably you you
specific you're probably better than
most men but in general like most men in
the nba can dunk wnb can't
and they and they get paid more because
they make more money like that like
women's ncaa has been at a loss for
years they don't even make money
why is that because because people don't
watch as much because it's just not as
entertaining who's i don't even keep who
runs the show who who's the top dog
the man because every time you know what
you know like no like if i like
i swear
i was like if i really want to watch a
women's game like i would watch a
women's game like that when it gets to
like certain levels like finals
semi-finals i like i was here but like
this is like and i'm a sports person so
like imagine people like that aren't
like it's sad it's sad because listen if
i was a woman i would [ __ ] hate men
i'd be like the feminists like
through them but it's like it is like it
is always with like on an individual
level what we're going to do is the
people
just one second just that fact in itself
what you're saying do you know i mean
and that is why there's those women
groups because of these situations it's
so hard for us to get jobs and then you
add
race into it you add where you live
ethnicity all these things are so
difficult so yeah there are only women
clubs there are only women gyms oh no
there's nothing
how are we devalued we got to stay at
home and not work that [ __ ] sounds
awesome
though yeah joe is he fighting with a
squad but but i'm saying like like like
even even the women but that was only
that came from like the war days where
the women had jobs in the war and then
the men came home and then they took
those women's jobs so then they got put
back in the home and now you have to
live well historically
like historically men had to fight in
war so how can we say we were oppressed
we never had to fight in wars no but i'm
saying
more honestly they're getting control
and then also
and even let's talk about the pay gap
like the reason that when men are paid
more than women is because they pick
industries that make more money
so like like if you go to the most
egalitarian countries in the world where
women have more choice
the the pay gap is bigger
because
men choose like professions with objects
where women's women choose professions
20 people wait wait shout them out i
will later no but i'm asking like like
our automatic gut reaction is always
that like it's about male and female
but like how do you know it's not just
the industries we pick
nah for short industry like industry is
a big thing
for you my album
now go ahead i've spoken my my part yeah
i agree with her a lot i can't lie um i
feel like there's just a lot of factors
like you can say okay cool like men get
to go work and the women get to stay at
home and it's all fun but it's not all
fun and games a lot of those women are
abused they're treated like crap like
that but why are they controlled but why
is that your immediate like like i just
don't understand why that's your
immediate gut reaction is to say like
they're at home because they're
controlled and they're abused and all
that stuff
like i know what i'm asking is that is
that your your your view on men it's
just that do you think the majority of
men are like abusing their women no but
i think a lot of those women are unhappy
and it comes from the old school days
like where they're actually suppressing
they're kind of taught they're brought
into that tradition and it just
continues where a lot of those women
actually are unhappy and they would like
to speak out and that's infamous if your
mom raised you like yo don't chase [ __ ]
from no man
like you would move completely different
cultures though different cultures
i'm saying she says all this culture i'm
like but it depends on like who you've
been raised by like some families invite
this something but that's what that's
where zania was like that's where race
comes into ethnicity a lot of those
things come like they're big factors
like we can all talk about the
positivity but there are other sides
like we're here to have a discussion on
all those different types of views so we
can't just say oh like yeah there's all
those women are happy but not all those
women are happy a lot of those who are
faking that happening
but how do you why is that your
assumption how do you know we don't but
that is yeah but you also see it from
one
um perspective
woman in a white world in america so you
only see one way so you don't really see
how the other different ethnicities
different cultures have completely their
women have to stay at home that is
you're saying that's really cool but as
women
we're starting to we want to be ceos we
want to be pushing where we're the equal
of men and this is what she's saying as
a young woman is saying like actually no
i would like to pay i would but do i
have the opportunities to make the same
money or do i have i've seen it even if
it's all these old schools
but i'm saying like like if that's true
like why in the countries where women
have more choice than ever is the pay
gap bigger so you can you can make a
list of countries right where women are
the most depressed and the least
depressed and the pay gap grows when
women have more choice
because of the industries they pick but
a lot of men so i'm not even talking
about other factors i'm just talking
about like male and female go ahead so a
lot of men do run those industries
though that determine those pays like a
lot of men even that they're very biased
in terms of like even internal
promotions and stuff within companies
but they can't change a pay grade like
of like yo you're a man
but i'm saying to to offset that we have
quotas so there are like i worked in
copier sales for two years that's a very
male dominated industry it's [ __ ] it's
awful like
oh my god
and they couldn't get women to stay
because it was terrible like it's a like
those those jobs are working 80 90 hours
a week my dad worked 80 hours a week my
whole life i do you want i don't want to
work 80 hours a week i don't know many
girls that do there's a lot of women
that actually are out there like even in
a lot of countries like they're working
a lot they're working like two free jobs
just to keep it yeah but i'm saying but
i'm saying if that's true then why in
the countries where they have the most
choice to do that do less women
like like you know we're all wealthy
like so then like what's the difference
so i'm saying like you go to the
countries where women have more choice
an opportunity to do those things and
they choose not to why if women want to
i think it's just a lot to do with like
history as well though like you're stuck
in a phase so maybe women i i'm not
saying women don't make there's a lot of
women that make stuff harder for
themselves like we do all have a choice
but there's a lot of circumstances that
dictate that like we can even go back
like i don't know this is relevant but
it actually makes sense to me like the
whole molly may like we all have 24
hours in a day like we actually don't
have the same 24 hours in a day like
everyone's circumstance is actually
different everyone says
there's so many factors that come into
that like like culture like everything
like it's just the opportunities don't
actually get given like as much as you
think they do that's a race thing it's
not like a gender thing for sure like
it's not just it's not just race though
like there's a lot of caucasian women
that face
disability like there's a lot of like
other other factors but i'm saying like
just pure gender are like
but then if you're like you would never
you wouldn't reject a job for like a
woman
over a man because you saw the name if
they had the same skills like well and
the other question is like why aren't we
rallying like we'll talk about ceo and
power positions but why aren't we
talking about women not wanting to be
things like garbage collectors plumbers
like all the hard jobs in the in the
military
like it's always like like that's what
i'm saying we only come along
there's a lot of women in the military
but they get treated like absolute [ __ ]
they don't get paid you know women
though you know i don't know any man
i don't know any women plumbers but i
know a navy person and he they
disrespect women like nothing they treat
them like [ __ ] and he's a high-ranking
person no that's not i don't like it and
so it's hard to be this but then there's
also it's like okay there's not men
beauticians like there's this job
there's just gender jobs that are just
like uh we're trying to break off why
can't there be a woman plumber why can't
there be a man who does my eyelashes
there's not enough man be like yo i want
to do eyelashes and then it's like
stereotypes
but this is why like i'm going back to
the same question where it's like we're
complaining about inequality when it
doesn't like benefit us